OLIVIA WU: Thank you
for being here.
I have been looking forward to
this talk and to meeting
Daphne, and having all of
you meet her, since I
knew she was coming.
She's a family physician.
She's a writer.
And she teaches in the
Department of Family Medicine,
UC San Francisco.
But first and foremost, I think,
it's just striking to
note that she's a doc.
She sits in her office three
days a week and sees patients
all day long, from birth
to age 102, and she
takes care of them.
And she's the first doc I've
taken around Google, and I've
taken many doctors around, who
said, let me take a picture of
the size of your desserts.
And let me take the picture of
the size of the cheese you're
serving, because I want to show
my patients how small
you're serving them.
This is how she cares
about her patients
and about their health.
And she prescribes good eating,
among other things.
And as she said to me at lunch,
if you care about your
food, you ultimately have to
find out and care about how it
is grown and where
it comes from.
So I'm so excited for her to
come and talk to us, to make
this connection between our
natural world, what's grown,
how it's grown, and how that
connects with our health.
I'm talked to quite often
by people who
say, there's health.
Tell me what I should eat
and what's good for me.
And then tell me about what's
good for the environment.
They have nothing to
do with each other.
And to me, they have
everything to
do with each other.
And I think Daphne's going to
talk to us about that, among
other things.
So she's also a writer.
She's a columnist for the
"Washington Post," in the
Health section.
And she's got these two books.
"Farmacology" just came out.
Very excited to see it
and to hear about it.
I thought I'd end by reading to
you some of the titles of
articles that she's written.
"Locavorism vs. Salmonella,"
"Take a hike and call me in
the morning," "Prescribing
Food," "Farm-Fresh Goat-Milk
Lattes."
And to me, this is the
fascinating thing about her.
She is comparing small family
farms, which I consider to be
in pretty fragile state, to
integrative medicine, medicine
for the whole person, and
drawing lessons from farming
when both of them are things
that are really kinda edgy.
So I can't wait to hear more.
Please welcome Daphne for me.
[APPLAUSE]
DAPHNE MILLER: Thank
you so much.
It's lovely to be here.
I have to tell you guys
that you're kind of
like my lucky penny.
Because five years ago, when
"Jungle Effect," my last book,
came out, it was at Google
that I gave one
of the first talks.
And that book went on
to do quite well.
And once again, this is one of
the very first talks that I'm
giving on "Farmacology," so
maybe I need to rub all of you
afterwards.
So I'm going to tell you a
story about soil and your
health today.
But first, I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how I
got into all of this
in the first place.
Maybe one way to illustrate it
would be to tell you about a
conversation I had with a
reporter a couple weeks ago.
This was a reporter that
was interviewing
me about the book.
And at the end of the interview,
he told me about
something that he'd seen down
at Stanford at their new
technologies, cool new
inventions expo.
And what it was, was a box.
And you could buy a cartridge,
just like you can for a
printer, and the cartridge
contained a plant and soil and
a computer chip.
And you would put it in the
box, and shut the lid, and
push the button, and you
would get a plant.
And the inventors, they're
actually on Kickstarter, were
saying this is great.
Now anybody can be a gardener
or a farmer.
And the interviewer wanted
to know what I
thought about this.
Well, the geek in me thinks
it's pretty darn cool.
What is that computer
chip doing?
And all you have to
do is add water.
Are you serious?
And this plant grows
on your counter.
And you need light,
but you don't
even really need sunlight.
And I was, like, on my phone
trying to find the website and
everything
But the healer in me had
some real hesitations.
How do we think that we can
reduce something so
complicated, something that
nature does with so many
elements as growing our food,
down to a cartridge and push
the button, and a
computer chip?
It's the same hesitancy I have
when I think, how can we
reduce something so complicated
as depression down
to one neurotransmitter, or
diabetes down to one hormone,
or cancer down to one missing
piece of DNA, or one excessive
piece of DNA.
And in fact, it is exactly
that concern about the
reductionism that sent me out of
my medical office to learn
from sustainable farmers.
Because from my vantage point,
I actually saw them as being
professionals, who were in
charge of healing an entire
system, that had thought about
all of those pieces, sun,
moon, bugs, rain, and brought
them all together to make
something grow.
And that was what I was
interested in doing in my
medical practice, is that kind
of complexity thinking.
So that was one of the first
things that started me looking
outside of the 8 by 10 walls
of my medical practice.
It was also my interest
in food.
And as Liv said, you talk about
food long enough, you
have to start to wonder
where it comes from.
And you have to start to get
beyond those words like,
organic or GMO.
These are just kind of labels.
You just have to understand
what's really
happening behind all that.
But I'd be misrepresenting
myself if I told you that I
had no background
in agriculture.
In fact, I was conceived
on a farm.
That might be too much
information.
You guys are just getting
to know me here.
My parents were part of the
back-to-the-land kibbutz movement.
They moved from a small town
outside of Massachusetts to
Israel in 1964.
And they were living
in a little, tiny
shack on the kibbutz.
I guess when you're living in
a single bed, the next thing
is you have a kid.
I don't know.
But my mother found out very
quickly that children on a
kibbutz are raised just
like the chickens.
They're basically kept
in a separate coop.
And she decided she did not want
a communal child, so I
was not born on the farm.
But I have my roots
on the farm.
But I was on this farm.
And that's me that you
see in the corner.
And this is a picture that was
actually sent to me very
recently when the farmer's
daughter found out that I was
writing this book.
But this is a piece of land in
upstate New York that my
parents bought when they moved
back to the States.
Actually, it was 150 acres.
And I think they bought it
with their stipend from
graduate school at that time.
But this was an introduction
to agriculture.
But I don't know if any of you
grew up on a farm or do some
farming now.
Is there anybody in the room
who is connected in
any way to the land?
OK.
Even gardeners, you count.
If you have a little box
out there, that counts.
OK, wonderful, everybody
in the room.
Well, this kind of farming, I
think you see what's happening
with the soil here.
It's being turned upside down
so that all that little
architecture of bugs and roots
and all these things that
nourish plants on the top, are
actually being turned deep
down into the earth where
they can't do very much.
But this was kind of what
farming had turned to in the
late 1960s when I'm standing
there in the corner.
My next experience with farming
actually happened in
medical school, where my best
friend, it turns out, in
medical school, was a goat
farmer from Mendocino.
And he'd been homeschooled all
the way until college.
And we would sit in the back
of the lecture hall.
And the professors would flash
these images or slides of
diseases up.
And he would sit next to me and
say, my goats get that.
Or, I know exactly
how that works.
Because I've taken care of
it for years on my goats.
And it was fascinating to me
that he was way more advanced
of a healer than I was because
of his experience on the farm.
And that stuck with me.
So then, my next experience
with farming--
I'm giving you sort of my
background in farming-- was as
an intern in the
Salinas Valley.
I went from Harvard Medical
School, which was sort of this
tertiary care,
hyper-reductionist, focused
specialty training to a family
medicine training in the
Salinas Valley.
And there I took care
of farm workers.
And it was the first time in my
life that I saw something
called organophosphate
poisoning, which was a
pesticide that's now illegal,
but then, in the early 1990s,
was still being used all
the time in the fields.
And I remember one of my first
times in the ER, being on
call, and this woman coming
in, pregnant, her fingers
stained black from picking
berries, seizing from
organophosphate poisoning.
And I saw an array of fetal
malformations in their busy
obstetrics ward that
I hadn't seen
during my previous training.
And so there it was really the
dark side of farming that I
was exposed to.
But my real interest in farming
probably happened the
same time as all of you, in
that I started to become
interested in sustainable
food, and this fantastic
movement of knowing your
farmer and going to the
farmers' market and hearing
about young idealists, people
in their 20s and 30s who were
giving up their fancy
educations and going back to the
land and starting to grow
vegetables, veritable
vegetables.
And I heard these stories.
And here I was, as a family
doctor in medicine, wondering
when are people going to be
clamoring for their medicine
to have a face the way they're
clamoring for their food to
have a face?
And when are we going to get
the same idealists who are
pouring into health and healing
and wanting to be
primary care doctors the same
way they want to be farmers,
underpaid primary
care doctors?
And I'm still waiting for
that movement to happen.
But that is one of the reasons
I started to look at this
paradigm of complexity and
sustainable farming.
But then, the more I started
to learn about farming, the
more I realized that farmers and
I have the same patients.
I started to look at,
actually, what they
do on a given day.
And you have to squint a
little bit here, OK?
But if you do, it's amazing, the
levels of the structures,
the way, actually, that they
work and that the nutrients
are moved from top to bottom.
And look at those hairs.
Their hair follicles look
surprisingly like soil.
I mean, there is a pattern here
that repeats itself not
just between the skin and
the soil but between the
intestinal lining and the
soil and the pulmonary
tree and the soil.
And then you start to look on
the electron microscope level.
Can you guess which one of
these is the villi in our
intestine interacting with
microbes and nutrients.
And In which one is roots
interacting with
microbes and nutrients?
Can you guess?
Don't read the bottom.
You cheated already.
But hard to tell, right?
So the one on your left
is the intestine.
And these are the intestinal
villi.
And this is the glycan, the
nutrients that are being
processed and brought in.
And this is the same with the
rhizosphere, with the roots
from plants.
And it works the same.
The organic matter comes in.
The microbes process it.
They put it into these perfect
packages, and then it gets
absorbed through these
finger-like projections,
whether it be in your
gut or in the soil.
And then, I started to learn
that the ideal pH of soil and
the ideal pH of our bodies are
pretty much exactly the same.
And the carbon-to-nitrogen
ratio of soil, and the
carbon-to-nitrogen ratio
that makes up our
being is darn similar.
And then, all of a sudden, it
dawned on me-- and I feel
pretty stupid that it took all
these years for it to dawn on
me as a physician--
but you know all those
carbohydrates and fats and
proteins that make
up our body?
Where do they come from?
They come from the soil
via our food.
In fact, it's not too
much of a stretch to
say that we are soil.
And when I started to think
about what that meant, all of
a sudden, my exploration
took on sort of
two levels of meaning.
There was the model
for farming that
interested me as a doctor.
And then there was the practice,
these things that I
could actually learn that I
call farm-to-body lessons,
that I could go out and bring my
patients so that they could
be healthier.
And "Farmacology"
is sort of the
culmination of all of that.
It's a whole series of lessons
from everything from a
laying-egg farm and what it can
teach us about different
kinds of stress, to a cow-calf
farm and what it can teach us
about super immunity or how to
build our resistance, to an
aromatic herb farm that teaches
us, actually, how
plants have special
messages for our
metabolism in our body.
But I'm going to tell
you one story today.
And as I said at the beginning,
it is the story
about soil and us.
And it starts, actually, with
this farmer here, Erick
Haakenson, and his wife Wendy.
Erick was actually not married
to Wendy when he bought his 12
acres of land in the Snoqualmie
Valley in
Washington State.
He bought it in the late 1980s
after having a varied career.
Unlike a lot of farmers, he
wasn't born into farming.
He actually had gone to Yale
Divinity School for a while.
And then he became a salmon
fisherman up in Alaska.
But then, in the late 1980s,
he wanted to fulfill a
lifelong dream, and he bought
12 acres in the Snoqualmie.
And his goal, as he explained
to me, was that he wanted to
grow vegetables that had
nutritional punch.
But as he started to farm the
land and plant his crops and
see what he was getting, he
realized that, in fact, his
soil was depleted.
It was tired.
It had no more nutrients
in it.
And now, from what you've just
learned, when your soil is
depleted, that means that your
vegetables are not going to
have nutritional punch.
And so he was a smart
man, a learned man.
So he went to the
agronomy books.
He went to the agricultural
science textbooks.
And he started to learn about
how to replenish his soil.
And he learned about what is
called testing and replacing,
where basically you go around
your property, and you take
samples in each one of the
fields that you're planning to
grow your vegetables in.
And then you take these samples,
and much like a test
tube, like you would with your
blood when you go to the lab,
and you send it off to a
central lab, that's an
agronomy lab.
And they send you back something
that looks very much
like this, very much like the
reports that I get in my
office for my patients.
You get one for each area
that you've sampled.
And it tells you if you have too
much of a mineral or too
little of a mineral.
It also tells you how
much to replace it.
And so Erick took all of this
information, being the dutiful
farmer, and he started
to follow directions.
So I'm going to actually take
a second and just read you a
tiny excerpt from the
book about this.
And it's Erick talking to me.
"'I spent days following up on
those computer readouts.
I used my John Deere cone
spreader and ended up putting
thousands of pounds of minerals
all on my 12 acres.'
He was not exaggerating.
I estimated, from the reports,
that in the years Erick used
the Agricultural Testing
Services, he'd spread more
than 50 tons of imported
minerals over his land.
'But somehow, it didn't
feel right.
There were lots of minerals
that I wasn't sure
where they were from.
They were probably taken from
developing countries where
their soil needed these minerals
more than we do.
And I was also wondering, if
these are all so good for my
plants, why does the
manufacturer recommended that
I wear a mask while I'm
spreading them?'
Plus, despite all his efforts,
Erick was not seeing the
miraculous improvements
that he'd hoped for.
He said, 'I couldn't help
thinking, yeah, I'm putting
these minerals on the soil,
but are they really
getting to the plant?
And if I happen to put down a
little too much of one thing,
what did it do to all
the other nutrients?
I'd heard stories about how
adding too much of one can
lock up other elements.
This could create soil
conditions that were even
worse than when I started.'"
So I'm sitting there, at Erick's
dining room table, and
he's telling me this story.
And as he's talking, all of a
sudden, I flash onto a patient
that I had seen in my office a
week before coming to his farm
to do this internship.
And her name was Allie.
I kind of changed her
name for the book.
It wasn't really Allie, but
we'll call her Allie.
And she was pretty typical
for my practice.
She was a woman in her 30s, who,
the best word I can find
to describe her, was depleted,
just like Erick's soil.
And she had had some intense
things happen in her life.
Her business had gone awry.
Her father had gotten
very sick.
She had been doing a lot of
traveling for her work.
And she started to get
very fatigued.
And she was going around and
seeing various physicians and
also seeing other healers.
And each time she would
go and see someone,
what would they do?
They would test her.
And then, they would get the
readouts, and they would
replace her.
And she was starting to be
this pharmacopoeia of
prescription medicines
and also supplements.
Meantime, her digestion
was going to pot.
She was just feeling terrible.
There was, like, this limited
diet that she could eat.
She'd get those bag things of
spinach and steam them,
because she knew she
needed some kind of
vegetable in her diet.
And then she would survive
on energy bars.
They were the only other thing
that would make her feel good.
And so she came to me, as sort
of this last-ditch resort, in
desperation, and wanted
to find out what I
recommended for her.
So this is a description of
my first visit with Allie.
"If Allie were sitting at the
table listening to Erick, I'm
certain that she would nod
her head in agreement.
To her first appointment in my
office, she brought in not
only her thick file of test
results but also two shopping
bags filled with prescription
pills and over-the-counter
supplements.
One by one, she unpacked them
onto my desk and a neighboring
bookshelf until my little exam
room looked more like a
vitamin shop than a
doctor's office.
The pharmaceuticals I could
recognize right away, a
proton-pump inhibitor for her
stomach, an antispasmodic for
her lower abdominal cramps, an
antidepressant for her mood,
an antihistamine for
her allergies.
But a good proportion of the
bottles in Allie's pharmacy
were labeled with vague names,
like Vital Force or Woman's
Thrive, rather than a
specific nutrient.
And when I read the fine
print, I saw that some
nutrients reappeared on a
multitude of bottles.
For example, I found five
supplements that contained
zinc and four others that
listed Vitamin A or its
metabolite retinoic acid.
Looking at this impressive
array, it was not too much of
a stretch to think of
Allie as locked up.
Indeed, any drug or supplement
can have unintended effects in
humans, like soil can become
deficient in one nutrient as a
result of having too
much of another.
For instance, excess calcium
can create zinc and iron
deficiencies in humans.
Interestingly enough, Erick told
me that excess phosphate
in the soil can create the same
deficiencies in plants.
I wondered how many adverse
interactions might be taking
place in Allie's fragile system
because of all the
drugs and supplements
she was taking."
So back to Erick.
I asked him, so what did you do
to make this beautiful land
that I've been farming for the
past couple days, as I was
sitting at the table.
And he told me the story about
how he actually ended up
rejuvenating his land.
He went back to the books.
But this time, he didn't go to
your standard agronomy books.
He went to books by the
grandmothers and grandfathers
of organic agriculture, people
whose names you might
recognize, like Rudolf Steiner,
and FH King, and Lady
Balfour, and Sir
Albert Howard.
These are people who wrote about
organic farming very
early on and influenced
people like the
modern day Michael Pollan.
These are the original organic
agricultural philosophers.
And how did they get
their opinions?
They got them from watching
traditional farmers farm on
the land, farmers who had been
farming a piece of land and
received it from their parents
and their great-grandparents
and their
great-great-grandparents and
planned to hand it down to
their children, and their
grandchildren, and their
great-great-grandchildren.
And so they had found a system
of preserving the soil and
preserving fertility
on the land.
And it didn't matter if they
were in China, like FH King
wrote about China, or if they
were in Germany and Bavaria,
like Rudolf Steiner, who wrote
about Germany and Bavaria, or
India, like Sir Albert Howard.
What they were all doing was
pretty much the same.
They were farming in the
image of nature.
They were farming the way
that nature farms.
How does nature farm?
Nature farms with animals,
not just with plants.
Animals are there to
replenish the soil.
Think of a natural setting
like a forest.
How does it happen?
The animals are part
of that ecosystem.
Nature always keeps
ground cover.
Have you ever been to a place in
nature, in the wild, where
you just see bare soil?
There's always something that's
protecting it and
preserving the moisture.
Nature doesn't till the way you
saw in that first picture,
where you take that delicate
top layer and
stick it down lower.
It can't do anything to
nourish the plants.
Nature doesn't use chemical
additives.
Nature conserves water.
Nature uses seeds that were
grown in that place, because
they're intended to be there,
not seeds that are actually
refined for a distant land
or that have another gene
introduced in them, as
we're seeing now.
So Erick became very influenced
by these writings.
And he, too, started to farm.
And his method is called
biodynamic farming.
But it really is this full
cycle of farming in
the image of nature.
And what he did, by doing this,
is he started to nourish
all of those microbes and all
of those worms and all of
those voles, the little rodents
that live under the
soil which are there to process
that organic matter.
And in turn, these billions
of unpaid workers began to
nourish his plants.
And he started to grow the most
amazing grass, because he
would rotate the animals
through.
I mean, what better fertilizer
than a cow, right?
They deposit it.
And then they plow it in
with their hooves.
And then they move on.
And they'll also disturb the top
layer just enough that you
start to get a little system
going on there.
So does that grass look pretty
good to you guys?
I mean, I know you're not
necessarily experts, but
wouldn't you say that's pretty
good looking grass?
Yeah, good grass.
And then he started to grow
amazing vegetables.
And he's just this very, very
popular farmer up in the
Snoqualmie.
But the true test is that
about 8 to 10 years into
having given up that test and
replace and changing his soil,
he went back, and he did
those soil samples.
And he sent them back
into the lab.
And the results came back that
everything was perfect.
And he hadn't bought an outside
additive in almost a decade.
So his new system was
really working.
So I'm sitting there, as a
doctor at the dining room
table, after having done a hard
day's labor in his field,
and I'm thinking, how
does this apply
to Allie, my patient?
Here she is in San Francisco
suffering, eating her energy
bars and her wilted spinach
from Costco and, you know,
eating her bags of medicines
every day.
Can I make the leap?
Can we start to say that when
Allie enters an eco-cycle that
she, too, can get healthier just
like his vegetables and
just like the cows and just like
the worms and just like
Erick and Wendy reported
for themselves
and their farm interns?
What would happen to Allie?
So I'm a woman of science.
So I started to go to the
literature to see what happens.
I mean, we have all of this data
now, telling us that if
it is a biodynamically rich
soil, if there's a lot of
worms and a lot of microbes that
are just teeming in that
soil, and there's a lot of
actual DNA in the soil, that
you grow a more nutrient-rich
and more varied crop.
Can you guys tell which is the
biodynamically rich soil here
just from looking
at this slide?
What's your guess?
The one on the left, yeah.
And you're not a
farmer, right?
You could just tell.
If you just even looked, not
at the greenery, but at the
soil itself, what do you
see that's different?
How would you describe
the two soils?
AUDIENCE: Happy.
DAPHNE MILLER: Happy.
AUDIENCE: Moist.
DAPHNE MILLER: Moist.
AUDIENCE: Rich.
DAPHNE MILLER: Rich.
Yeah, there's something about
it that feels pliable, like
that it can give, like it can
allow earth to come through.
You're not going to
believe this.
But as a doctor, when I look at
my patients, I apply a lot
of these same values.
This is what you learn.
Is that recognized?
Healthy, sick?
And this was fascinating for
me to see that I had this
language, actually, in common
with farmers, our ability to
sort of evaluate things.
But we have a lot of data now
showing us that microbes in
the soil, in this rich soil,
have everything to do with the
value of the nutrients
that come out of it.
And I don't know if you guys
are familiar with the study
that came out of Stanford about
nine months ago, saying
that organic is no better
than conventional.
It's because they were asking
the wrong question.
If they'd been asking
about the soil--
because there's many organic
soils that look like that.
In fact, that's an
organic soil--
if they were asking, does
microbial-rich soil and well
cared for eco-soil like Erick's
produce happier
vegetables, their study
would have had a
totally different result.
Isn't it amazing in science, if
you ask the wrong question,
you really go down
the rabbit hole.
So we have lots of information
about this.
This is not disputed
at this point.
And we have lots of information
that nutrient-rich
foods makes for healthy
people.
We have that information, too.
But we haven't completed the arc
from soil to our bodies.
How do we relate to soil?
What happens if I put Allie
in that eco-cycle?
What happens if I put you in
that eco-cycle to your health?
And these are the kinds
of cross-disciplinary,
big-picture questions that we
need to start asking and not
get caught in our click-and-grow
bubble, you
know, of putting the plant
in the box or the
human on the drug.
So I called lots
of scientists.
I asked them this question, what
happens to us when we get
connected to healthy soil?
Can we actually turn
our health around?
And most of them, there
was silence at
the end of the phone.
I talked to people in health.
I talked to people
in agronomy.
But one day I called
Justin Sonnenburg.
And he's a microbiologist
at Stanford.
Do you recognize his slide
there on his desktop?
You saw that earlier, right?
That's the one I showed
you of the human gut.
What Justin and his wife
Erica do-- they're a
team in their lab--
and they study the microbiome,
which is that massive colony
of bacteria that lives
in our intestine.
Two pounds of us is bacteria
that we don't own in terms of
it not being part of our DNA
but that we're discovering
more and more has everything
to do with our health.
It has to do with our propensity
for allergies.
It has to do with our
level of immunity.
It has to do with
our metabolism.
It might even have to do with
whether we are heavy or thin.
These are all things that are
related to the microbiome.
And if you're interested in
reading more, "Mother Jones"
has a fantastic article that
just came out, I think, last
week but specifically on it.
It's one of the best
pieces I've seen.
But there's more and more coming
out about how much
these little bugs in our gut
sort of rule our health.
And what we're discovering is
that a certain percentage of
these we inherit the same way
we inherit property or our
grandmother's candlesticks.
They come to us within
our family lineage.
But there's another percentage
of them that we get from our
environment and we get from a
variety of places, including
the places where our food is
grown, the soil and water.
Water is the oceans or where
our food is grown, as well.
Sometimes we don't think of that
as the water equivalent
of soil, but it is.
And so Justin said, we're just
starting to discover how the
microbes, those microbes that
Erick is growing in his soil,
interact with our microbiome and
what effect that's having
on our health, and that that
might explain at least a good
part of what happens to someone
like Allie in terms of
her health when she enters
the farm cycle.
But I'm just going to share with
you some of the research
that's coming out on this.
And this is new stuff, guys.
I've gone from ancient farmers
to sort of cutting edge
microbiology here.
But what we're starting
to discover--
and this is a study that just
came out a couple months ago--
is that when your food is grown
in soil that's been
mistreated, that's been dosed
with antibiotics and
pesticides and fertilizers, the
bacteria that's encouraged
to grow in that soil, first
of all, it becomes very
monotonous.
You don't get the huge variety
that you got in that slide
that you appreciated.
You tend to get fewer
types of bacteria.
And they develop antibiotic
resistance.
And then what happens is they
hitchhike on your food into
your gut, and they give
information--
sometimes it's just
a segment of DNA--
to your microbiome.
And they actually can
convert good guys.
They can convert the nice
candlesticks that you got from
your grandmother into
antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
And so we're starting to
discover that, you know, we've
known that when you dose animals
with antibiotics that
that affects your own resistance
to antibiotics.
We're starting to discover that
soil is a whole other
piece of this.
And we just don't even know what
other kind of negative
information can come in from
having your food grown in
negative soil.
They're just starting to code
these strands and figure out
what this little invisible
exchange is that's happening.
So now I've told you
the bad news.
But the good news--
and this is a piece
that Justin wrote.
It's about research that
researchers in France did--
but we're discovering that
good information gets
transferred, as well.
So this is about a study that
was done where researchers
went and looked at a bacteria
that lives on
seaweed in the ocean.
And this bacteria has a sequence
of DNA in it that's
really good at digesting seaweed
and processing those
nutrients and using it.
And it's bacteria
that's called a
Bacteroidetes type bacteria.
And so now that we can sequence
the entire genome,
and we're starting to be able to
sequence the entire biome,
they went in, and they started
to look at where they could
find that enzyme that digests
the seaweed in terms of all
living species.
And they found it in the
intestines of cultures that
eat a lot of seaweed.
And so what happened is
that that bacteria
passed its DNA on.
It hitchhiked on the seaweed
into the microbiome of these
seaweed-eating cultures.
And as a result, they have
a better ability than non
seaweed-eating cultures
to digest seaweed
and harvest its nutrients.
They have these special
Bacteroidetes that are sort of
like seaweed gluttons, and that
give them all these great
nutrients from seaweed.
But let's say, if your family
grew up for centuries in
Eastern Europe, you don't
have that ability.
And as Justin Sonnenburg
said, this is just
the tip of the iceberg.
How much of this information,
this pass-the-gene game, is
happening between us and our
soil at every given meal,
we're just starting
to discover.
I'm not going to load you with
a bunch of this new research,
but I need to tell you
this other study,
because I just love it.
This is Italian researchers who
went to a tiny village in
Burkina Faso and, actually--
it's kind of a weird study--
they took a group of healthy
children in the village and
collected stool samples from
them and studied the bacterial
content of their stool.
And then they went and compared
these stool samples,
the bacterial colonies in it, to
a sample from kids who were
living in downtown Florence.
And I don't know if any of you
have been to Florence lately,
but they have a McDonald's on
every corner, just like we do
here in the urban US.
And those kids, they have the
same childhood obesity problem
in Italy that we have.
So a really different
sample of kids.
These are kids in Burkina Faso,
who, the best way to
describe it is that they
are eating this full
cycle form of farming.
They are eating from land
and soil that's
very much like Erick's.
So the result that they saw
was that the children in
Burkina Faso, the green
is that Bacteroidetes.
It's that type of bacteria that
tends to be very good.
There's many different
species of them.
But they're all, in general,
very good at harvesting whole
grains and greens and taking
those nutrients and passing
them on to you, versus
firmicutes, which is what you
see a preponderance
of in Florence.
And this looks much more like
our intestine, when they
sample people here
in the West.
Firmicutes thrive on
a McDonald's meal.
They're great at taking
saturated fats and lots of
sugar and harvesting
those nutrients and
moving them into you.
Those are kind of the Homer
Simpson of bacteria.
And so, also, from the children
from Burkina Faso,
they discovered that they had
types of bacteria that we
don't even have in our Western
guts and that look a lot more
like bacteria that they found
when they took these ancient
stool samples from
archaeological sites, from
people in Mesopotamia, and
looked at what their bacteria
looked like.
They are able to code the DNA
in these ancient stools.
The name for ancient stools, by
the way, is coprolites, in
case you're in a trivia game
ever, and you need to
come up with that.
But they looked a lot more like
the Burkina Faso kids.
So the point here is that part
of our microbiome is going
extinct as we move away from
these traditional soils and
these traditional ways
of farming and
these traditional foods.
We're actually losing the
bacteria which are our friends
and can help us metabolically.
And so learning all of this, I
really started to wonder, so
what would happen if Allie
really reconnected with the
farm and became a piece
of the farm?
And I started to talk to her
about this idea, based on what
I'd learned with Erick.
And I kind of came up with this
little set of rules for
how to reconnect
with the farm.
I came up with seven
ideas here for her.
The first one was to eat
a little dirt and bugs.
And it was obviously from food
that's been grown in an
authentic and full-farming
way.
If you eat that food from the
farm that I showed you in that
slide that's causing antibiotic
resistance, the
dirt from that farm that's
causing antibiotic resistance,
that's not going to
be recommended.
But eat a little dirt and bugs
from a farm like Erick's.
Who knows what kinds of
information is coming along?
And someone, at a talk I gave
recently, told me that there
are some chefs that are starting
to serve sprinklings
of soil, actually,
on the plate.
So this is becoming very
trendy, I guess.
But for those of you who can't
stand the idea of that,
fermented foods are really a
chance to eat soil bugs.
Have you ever thought
about that?
Fermentation is actually just
controlled rotting.
What it is, is you take
the vegetable, and
you put it in salt.
And whenever you buy real
fermented food, it should just
be vegetable and salt.
There should be nothing else
on the ingredients.
If you want a couple herbs
in there, fine.
But if it says vinegar, or
preservative, or sugar, just
put it back on the shelf, OK.
It should be vegetables
and salt.
And what happens is that
the bacteria--
the lactobacillus that's sitting
on the vegetable, that
came from where?
The soil--
it starts to ferment it.
It does its work.
And when it ferments,
it multiplies.
It grows.
And so when you eat a little
tablespoon of sauerkraut,
you're getting billions
of bacteria.
And they're not just some
bacteria that some scientists
dreamed up, which is what you
get when you take those
probiotics, they're ones from
the soil that you co-evolved
with for millions of years.
And so it makes sense.
Those are the ones
you want to get.
Another pointer I gave to her--
we're always telling
people, buy food that's
locally grown.
Buy food from a farmer
that has a face.
You guys are busy.
You don't know how to do that.
Or you get it from your
cafeteria here.
Let's say you're going to pick
out a piece of fruit or a
vegetable--
the best way is to look at the
piece of fruit and vegetable,
and smell it.
And if you can take a little
taste, if it's a grape if it's
something like that,
take a taste.
If it tastes wonderful, and if
it smells good, chances are
it's been grown in
a wonderful way.
Because most of our
conventionally and mass-grown
stuff and stuff that's been
grown through bad soil, its
seed has been either engineered
or hybridized to
succeed anywhere and to be
transportable and not
perishable and all
of those things.
It's not a seed that has been
maximized for taste and for
nutrient value.
And taste and nutrient value
often run together.
So I really encourage people to
actually get to know their
vegetables through their nose
and their mouth and not
through their eyes.
And when you use your eyes,
look for imperfection, OK?
Usually stuff that's been
grown in a local and
sustainable way, it's going
to be a little lopsided.
It's not going to look like
some beauty queen that's,
like, puffed up and been given
lipo and Botox and is
completely the same
as the next one.
And the vegetables and fruits
that are a little bug-eaten,
that's where most of the
nutrients are, because
antioxidants are basically
like a vegetable's
equivalent of a scab.
They're the place that it goes,
that it actually uses to
fight whatever bug
or whatever.
It's their immune system.
So look for the cabbage leaves
that are a little moth-eaten.
Don't throw those
outer ones away.
Or if someone else is throwing
them away, you go eat them.
Choosing food with a story is
a little different than
choosing local food, because
we don't have the luxury
around this country of getting
stuff fresh and local the way
that we can in San Francisco
or the Bay Area.
But choose food where there's
something about the farm on
the label in the store that says
where it's grown, talks
about the farmer.
I was speaking with Wendell
Berry, who's belongs in that
food philosopher category.
And he told me one of the ways
that he vets his food is he
finds out does the farmer
live on the farm?
So much of our commercial food,
the farmer's wearing a
suit and working in
a city somewhere.
And that farm is owned by
someone who really isn't even
invested in the soil, whose
grandfather and
great-grandfather wasn't part of
it or who doesn't have the
plans to keep it wonderful so
they can pass it on like an
heirloom to their children
and grandchildren.
But the minute that the farmer
becomes invested in the soil
and preferably owns that soil,
they're going to take care of
it like the most precious family
heirloom, and they're
going to give you, and they're
going to give their own
family, delicious food.
Another important thing,
and this is just
self-evident, is to cook.
Because that's when you start
to use these materials.
And I know here you have this
wonderful food served to you
during the day.
And I know that your chefs and
your food procurers are doing
an amazing job here.
But when you go home, use the
same kind of mindfulness.
And another important
piece of it is to
give back to the soil.
I don't know how many of you
live in a place where you can
do communal composting or you
have access to your own
compost bins.
I mean, even if you live in a
high-rise apartment in San
Francisco now, you can
contribute to the green bins
with your food scraps.
Saving water, taking a shorter
shower is a way to give back
to the soil.
Because any water you don't use,
in the global picture,
can be diverted towards
agriculture.
And connecting with nature, in
the book, it's in the sixth
chapter of the book, I talk at
length about all of these
chemical connections that we
have with nature and how,
actually, there are messages
when we work with plants, both
olfactory messages and so on,
that can make us happy or can
change our outlook on things.
We are actually having this sort
of secret conversation
with nature that we don't
even realize.
So just getting around nature.
Farming is great.
Gardening can be great.
I wrote a chapter that took
place in the Bronx in the book
with urban farmers.
And one of the researchers, who
is studying urban farmers,
found out that they were
healthier and thinner even if
they weren't growing vegetables,
just because being
outside, perhaps connecting
with the plants.
Who knows what it was?
And the most important thing is
to treat your body the same
way as you would treat
your food.
So anything you put on your
body or put in your house,
think of it as something that
eventually is going to end up
in your soil.
Because it will.
So when you're buying shampoos,
or makeup, or
moisturizers, or cleaners for
your car, or detergents for
your laundry, or your
toothpaste, look for all of
those bisphenol As,
those VOCs.
If it's something that you don't
want to take immediately
and eat yourself, don't put it
on your body, don't put it in
your house, because it will
end up back in your food.
Vinegar is a fantastic
cleaning resource.
I use it as a cleaning fluid
for everything in my house.
Believe it or not, baking soda
is the best shampoo I've ever
discovered, cocoa butter
for your skin.
And these things have everything
to do with the farm
and have everything to
do with your soil.
And the other thing that I
didn't write up there, and
this is really important, is
to treat your body the same
way as a mindful farmer treats
their soil, because sometimes
we care more about the soil than
we do about ourselves,
which is very interesting.
So I shared all of
this with Allie.
And we strategized about how
she, in her San Francisco
life, could start to do this.
And she actually started
to get a CSA box.
And she started to volunteer in
a school garden, and just
made more time to be outside,
and made more time to cook,
and started to have a different
idea about how she
was choosing her food.
And she slowly started to get
herself off of those shopping
bags full of medicine.
The one medicine--
because I saw her recently--
she still takes an
antidepressant.
But everything else,
she stopped.
My guess is that the
antidepressant, at this point,
it's a pretty low dose.
But she holds onto it.
And I'm totally fine
with that.
I'm an integrative doctor,
and I like to
straddle both worlds.
But who knows what piece
of all of this worked?
Was it the subtle messages
from the plants?
Was it the microbes?
Was it her just getting off all
those medicines that were
interacting with
her microbiome?
Who knows?
Was it her, just all of a
sudden, having a different
outlook, a different view?
But about six months after she
made these changes, just like
Erick, we sent lab
tests on Allie.
And they came back.
All of her labs-- all of the
subtle deficiencies in iron
and Vitamin D and so on,
that all of those other
practitioners had
been replacing--
they were normal.
And so I called Erick and told
him, and he kind of high-fived
me over the phone.
So we both realized that we'd
done pretty much the same
intervention.
So this picture is just to show
you-- this comes from
another chapter of the book.
It's about raising
resilient kids--
but this is the kind of
connection that other cultures
have with their farms and their
soil, and this kind of
trust that they have, that
there's real health there.
And I just wanted to
show you that.
But thank you so much
for listening.
And please, spread the word
about "Farmacology." Go ahead
and Facebook me.
I just started on Twitter.
But I've become a
Twitter fanatic.
I think it's this great
way to learn things.
And I share new studies
every day.
Because I think you can tell,
I'm a little bit of a science
geek on top of being
a holistic healer.
And any new research I find, I
like to put out via Twitter.
So follow me on Twitter.
And thank you so much.
It was such a pleasure.
And I'll take any questions
you guys have.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: If you
have a question--
AUDIENCE: So there's obviously
a richer microbiome in soil
than in air, sort of in the rest
of the environment where
people live.
And I know there's some emerging
research in that
area, too, about what kinds of
microbes are in our different
environments.
And are you familiar
with that?
How important do you think
that is, to our health?
DAPHNE MILLER: We don't know.
I mean, like I said, the ocean
is another enormous source.
And soil, obviously, is
a very huge source.
I think it makes sense that the
places where our food is
grown is where we're going to
get the most beneficial
influence from that.
But in the chapter on resilience
and resistance that
I talk about, there's a number
of researchers that are
studying how farm kids have way
less allergy and asthma
than children who live
in urban areas.
And they are discovering
that microbes in their
unpasteurized milk play a role,
that actual microbes
that are just in the hay
dust play a role.
A lot of the yeast that they
are discovering, yeast that
even we thought were pathogenic
or bad for you in
these urban environments, might
actually be good for you.
And they're even discovering
that types of bacteria that we
equate with poisoning or
disease, things like staph and
listeria, that in these little
doses in farm environments,
they're actually protective.
So this is just a
wide open field.
And next week, I'll have
something new to tell you,
because the literature is just
changing very quickly.
AUDIENCE: I heard Mary Roach was
going to be talking about
her latest book.
And she was talking about
transplants of, like, even
fecal matter into patients,
that kind of thing.
I thought it was pretty
interesting.
And I'm quite interested in the
whole rise and shine kind
of cleansing type thing where
people are replacing the biome
essentially in their bodies.
I was wondering you if you
had a viewpoint on
people doing that?
DAPHNE MILLER: Well, when things
go bad, then fecal
transplants actually can be
unbelievably powerful.
Unfortunately, the FDA is coming
down on it, because
it's foreign tissue, and
that gets regulated.
It used to be sort of this
underground thing that
gastroenterologists would
do in some weird
places in the country.
But now, as it's getting more
popular, I think, pretty soon
it's going to be a very
regulated thing, like
everything.
But most of the time, we don't
need to go to that extreme.
Most of the time we can actually
nurture our biome by
eating these correct foods.
But there are some instances
in my practice where I have
referred patients for
fecal transplant.
But those are people who are
really, really ill and where
all these other things
haven't worked.
And the next question is, where
did they get the healthy
feces from?
They usually get it from a
parent or a family member,
someone who shares
the candlesticks
with them, as well.
But it's kind of a last-ditch
solution.
And another question that I get
a lot is, how about those
over-the-counter supplements,
those probiotics?
And even people like Justin
Sonnenburg, what they're
really doing is trying to mine
all this information to come
up with the ideal probiotic.
Because that's where
the biotech is.
That's where the money
is, right?
What I'm talking about, eating
vegetables and getting to know
the soil, I'm never going
to get rich on this.
But the problem with probiotics
is, because just as
I was talking about, a lot of
our microbiome is inherited.
So yours might look very
different than the gentleman
in the red shirt behind you
and maybe different from
someone in the checkered
shirt here.
And so what is the
ideal microbiome?
We don't know.
Should we be trying to look,
once again, like those
children in Burkina Faso?
Probably.
But it's going to be really hard
to get back there with
our modern-day diets,
you know.
And it doesn't matter how
many probiotics you
dump into the system.
That's just a living bacteria
that needs to be nourished in
order for it to continue
to grow there.
Does that makes sense?
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]